it's still crazy to me that like after
just a year where china unleashed a
pandemic on the world that killed
millions of people they've cracked down
on on hong kong they've they've
committed a genocide and the world
responds by sending all of their
athletes there to compete in the
olympics i want people are gloating at
all these athletes who are getting
injured and and screwing up there's that
one uh chinese-american woman who
uh uh she she recently she what's the
what's the word she abandoned are you
talking about eileen goo the skier no no
no no she she just like slipped on her
skis or whatever oh you're talking about
an injury okay no i'm talking about that
woman who fell uh ice skating
and uh she had renounced her american
citizenship to skate for china instead
of america wait what i didn't see that
yeah and that happened yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah a chinese-american born woman
renounced u.s citizenship to uh i think
i have it maybe
because when you when you said that i
was thinking of here we go yeah
you
falls again breaks down and tears the
olympics people are making fun of her
because uh she gave up american
citizenship and now she's fallen twice
and uh people in china are mocking her
and insulting her and laughing at her
yeah sad i mean i was thinking i was
thinking of the skier
or the skier
who was born in america and grew up in
san francisco
her mom her mom was from china and she
competed for the u.s until two years ago
and she switched to china and is now
competing for china in the olympics is
she is she the one who shattered her leg
no i don't think so her name's her
name's eileen goo
you sure
i believe so something about a shattered
leg i didn't i mean i haven't watched
like the olympics at all for obvious
reasons so i don't no no no
was she i don't know there's uh there
was two one there was i think she was
the one who lost one of her skis but
then just like slid it out and was
totally fine but there's another skier
who was doing slalom and she like
slipped out and then her legs spiraled
and she like fractured her tibia or
whatever what's the bone down there is
the tibia the tibia is the toe bones the
fibula is the finger i know t and f
that's how i remember oh is it yeah no
what's what's the femur is the lydia
looks like she's the doctor femur is
like that biggest bone the biggest bone
he said phibia yeah the phybia i believe
that's in the leg i think this one am i
wrong about that it's not toes and
fingers i'm so sorry if i'm wrong about
that i thought tibia in february and you
roll the one my dad told me that 30
years ago i'm looking it up you guys
femur breaks also the the the bone
between your knee and your foot that one
that's like the femur no no the femur is
your thigh
and your foot it's your biggest bone
yeah yeah
fibula yeah okay i thought it was tibia
i was way off but she like armed is the
arm she like spiraled it it was brutal
the tone yeah but that is that is a
really good point that uh oh it's the
fibula it's different than the phibia i
guess those are different
people i i all of these athletes who are
agreeing to this i'm just i'm sitting
back with my feet up while they're all
complaining about the conditions they
have to go through because apparently
like communist china is unpleasant who
would have known would have guessed all
these athletes are like it's so
miserable here and i'm like
don't go dude i'm sorry people are like
but they've but they've worked so hard
their whole lives for the olympics and
it's like so what there was that woman
who was a chess grandmaster refused to
go to iran because she wasn't gonna wear
a hijab and i'm like that's awesome yeah
good for her she was like screw that i
ain't doing it and i'm like yes start a
youtube channel play chess online
but these people show you what they care
more about they chose what they care
more about these people who are willing
to go to china to compete all every
single one of them they care more about
a piece of gold on their neck than they
do about concentration camps about
potential war and conflict about what's
going on in hong kong i think it's gross
like actors with the emmys and the
oscars you want to get that medal do
anything same thing bend down and stay
quiet you get that medal
yeah i mean i i was an athlete growing
up so like i understand if you're
someone who's playing a sport your whole
life you know you dream of going to the
olympics this is your chance like i get
it like i get it
you know it's hard to give that up it's
just to make just to make a political
statement like i'm i'm i'm thinking like
it like it's like put yourself in their
shoes like if you're someone who's been
training your entire life in this sport
the olympics is your dream it's hard
like it's hard to give that up i don't i
don't that's why i i don't like i don't
really blame anyone for doing this i
blame you know america for not standing
up and saying no we're not sending our
people to china
why is it incumbent upon the government
to stop athletes as individuals well no
not the gov i'm not necessarily the
government i'm talking about like you
know the governing body of usa
athletics right if if the usa came out
and boycotted the olympics they'd be
forcing all the athletes but the
athletes could just choose not to go
yeah that's true
but like but but but but like i said
like it's hard like it's really tough
like if you're if you're an athlete like
that like i understand that would that's
a that's a tough decision to make i i
just as someone who played sports my
whole life sure and i mean i agree that
it's a tough decision but also just
because it's the difficult decision
doesn't mean it isn't the right one and
often times it is i'm i'm really
confused i don't think it's a difficult
decision at all like well he's saying no
i i don't think it's a difficult
decision morally i think it's very
straightforward i think you don't go i
think what he's saying is that they have
to make a large personal sacrifice but
what i'm saying is even if you have to
make a large personal sacrifice to do
the right thing you should still do it
and i do blame them for not yeah it's
like how many how many uh
like how many people murdered in
genocide is too much for you as an
olympic athlete you know what i mean
exactly because clearly because clearly
what's happening to the uyghur muslims
what's happened to hong kong what
they're threatening over taiwan is that
enough for any of these people to be
like yeah maybe i don't go into beijing
on this one didn't and would it be funny
if if even a small fraction of all the
olympic athletes were like hey we're not
gonna we're not gonna compete as
individuals i just i'm not gonna go to
china and then china would have to be
like maybe we should stop doing this to
the weaker muslims because we're losing
out on the olympics what uh jesse owens
i'm thinking of 1936 berlin olympics
nazi germany he went and performed black
guy and like it was like a big deal in
nazi germany and he won four gold medals
yeah and he made a global statement and
that was a big deal so there's a chance
for people to go to china and be like yo
down with communism but nancy pelosi is
like please don't do that because
they're crazy over there i don't i don't
like the whole go and protest
at the event thing you know i said it
before i'm just like maybe sporting
should just be sporting
and because they they're banning like
they announced they banned black lives
matter at these events and i'm like yeah
well you know maybe if people want to
just go and compete and doesn't have to
be political all the time every single
time however
i think it's also fair to then be like
you don't got to protest there but you
also don't have to go there you know the
olympics have always been very neutral
even way back to athens in the original
olympics it was a it was a time for all
these different athenian uh or all these
different greek nations to come together
even if they were at war with each other
they they agreed that they would let the
athletes pass through their territory
even if countries they were worth to go
to the olympics because it was so fun it
was just like that's the human you know
that we play
what do you guys so what do you guys
think of the world cup so we have the
world cup coming up too in november and
it's in guitar and apparently and
they're building and so how many corpses
are in the stadium
so so they had to move it so usually
it's in the summer but they moved it to
november because of how hot it gets
there in the summer and apparently like
there are reports that they're using
like slave labor to build oh yeah of
course of course for a long time their
their their uh reports
i i i could be wrong about this so
fracturing me it's been a long time
since i read about this but like uh
corpses in the rubble as they're
building it's just like oh somebody died
well bury over them it's crazy i mean it
just shows how like corrupt you know the
international governing bodies of the
olympics and of the of fifa are the
ideas that they give like these these
these countries somehow got the chance
to host this you got to understand how
people are
how people are is that
they've spent their whole life
working towards a goal there is nothing
that will stand in their way for these
18 19 year old olympic athletes who are
skiing or snowboarding they're like yo
look
i know that china has
these uighur muslims these women being
raped by by han chinese men and force
impregnated i know they're doing forced
abortions and sterilization but i want
that gold medal dude come on
i don't care how many people they kill
in those camps right is that what
they're saying i think these people are
disgusting i think it's a very sad
reality and it's been difficult to see
that in many cases people only care
about morality insofar as their
reputation requires it and so
we're on a we're at a place where i
imagine most people would spend more
time criticizing atrocities of the past
like nazi germany or transatlantic
slavery uh than they would criticizing
actual atrocities in the world that
people won't pat them on the back so
much for addressing yeah there's no
sacrifice complaining about the past
exactly and so i mean
again is there a statistical analysis
done on this no but based on the
conversations i've had particularly with
left-leaning people i think there is
currently a lot more criticism going on
about nazi germany which ended in the
1900s right late 40s then there is
criticism of communist china which is
actually engaged in genocide right now
did you guys see this story about
savannah guthrie
china using uyghur athlete olympic
ceremony and in your face response to
the west this moment is quite
provocative it's a statement from the
chinese president xi jinping
dude we are we are heading towards a
future where there is chinese communist
authoritarianism you mentioned there was
already one athlete who defective i
guess apparently more than one who's
defected from the united states to go
perform for china lebron james may as
well go do it he's he's defended china
you've got mark cuban and apparently
elon musk is using social media what is
it weibo or whatever okay weibo i don't
know we i can't remember who we had on
the show they were talking about how
elon musk will say all these great
freedom things on twitter but then he's
also on chinese social media praising
china yeah we talked about oh did you
see this video got taken down by twitter
too the original account that oh yeah
look at that we did it it got taken down
it's been disabled in response to a
report by the copyright and so so the
copyright owner is that nbc in this case
apparently yeah like
getting a video of one of their
reporters the stories that have come out
of china over what's happening to the
weaker muslims i hope you guys realize
it is it's on par
with like the some of the worst
atrocities we've ever heard of in the
history of mankind like forced abortions
like taking women and holding them down
and forced abortions for sterilization
bringing men in to rape these women
these these stories some of the the
images and the videos that have that
have come out are some of the most
nightmarish and grotesque things we've
ever seen and and and disney is
producing films in these regions and
apparently none of it matters none of it
matters to any one of these big
corporations none of it matters to these
that's right
money money
got to get paid yeah i mean i think a
big difference between you know
atrocities between china and you know
authoritarian countries in the past that
have committed atrocities is that
china like we've never seen the amount
of financial interest that china has
with the with the west like it's
incomparable to like the soviet union or
any of any of these other countries like
the like
the influence china has over the biggest
corporations in the world the biggest
corporations in america who are just
drunk on their chinese dollars
like that's that's the difference that's
why that's why that's why it's it's all
about money i earlier you mentioned um
that what the way you're saying it was
that you said the chinese unleashed the
the virus on the world i want i want to
create some nuance because i think it's
more that there was a technocratic
scientist group of scientists that did
it well at least because
i guess
covered up one may have been a better
but the poor people the people of china
are like suffering i mean i don't know i
don't know i'm not there and i'm not a
chinese but it looks like that they're
underneath this substrate they're the
subs underneath the substrate i don't
mechanical authoritarianism or something
i mean i would i would somewhat agree
with that but what do you think they say
about us i don't know probably similar
things they criticize our censorship on
social media they criticize our police
they it was really interesting there's
this meme of doctors walking down a hall
and all these superheroes are bowing to
them and i thought it was really
interesting because bowing isn't really
an american thing it's more of an an
asian thing
wouldn't like so i'm wondering where did
this meme come from and i'm not
insinuating anything by it in terms of
who made it i'm just wondering
you know why wouldn't it be
clapping for like superheroes clapping i
wonder if we evolved our bows to nods
well what i mean is it's more subtle now
that it has long been uh
why it's widely believed that china they
have something called the 50 cent armies
they propagandize on the internet they
get paid to do it
they're the you know they're widely
censored but
i think it's a fair assumption that part
of the the cold war with china is that
they're flooding our social media with
divisive and and you know divisive memes
to create conflict and so so division in
this in this country now the advantage
they have is that they've greatly
censored the internet preventing the us
from doing similarly
we well we're susceptible to it so
imagine over in china they're saying
things like the american people think
they're free they're not there's that
hilarious propaganda video of north
korea where they're like homeless people
they starve they have no health care and
things like that which are all
technically the truth of course it's way
better here than it is in north korea
but they highlight the worst or the
worst and claim the worst possible
things are happening and i'd be willing
to bet that for a lot of people
in
china they don't know anything about
uighur muslims they have no idea it's
happening so their media is all saying
we're bad our media is saying they're
bad and here we are gearing up for some
kind of conflict over taiwan well for a
lot of like chinese college students who
come to america like my sister knew a
few at her college they they didn't know
what tiananmen square was before they
moved here they didn't know you know
they didn't know about any of the they
didn't know what the great leap forward
was how many people it killed before
they came here
it's it's crazy here's zero man pol pot
tiananmen square's nuts that was what
1993 when this early 90's it was a big
protest of college students and like
intelligentsia came out to protest
communism and it was like hey we're here
now we finally this is it and then the
communist government ruled out tanks and
mowed down crowds of people the tank man
tries to censor it and like on that day
they'll ban like that word from
different uh social
sites and stuff like it's hard to find
it on that day because you can see the
ccp's trying to stop people from knowing
that it happened yeah i'm just someone
super chatted something about blm and in
china we'll read it when we get super
chats but i just think it's gonna be
funny when
invariably we get some celebrity or some
some athlete in the at the olympics who
like raises the red salute and then yell
something for black lives matter in a
country that's for sterilizing
minorities
with 1989 tianmin square protests and
massacre
but it's not the first thing that comes
up when you search for it even on
duckduckgo it's brutal man i mean i
guess it's it's today tiananmen square
hotels you know but i i think uh
people might view this as pessimistic i
don't think it's so pessimistic but i
think china's gonna win
why do you mean win they're gonna
they're gonna become the dominant global
power all the countries will become
deferential to china instead of the us
china will expand military bases they
already are all over all over the planet
and then the united states will be kind
of much more like russia than the uh so
our cost of living will go up
dramatically
you know we'll probably bring more labor
and and project and products will be
manufactured in the us
but life will generally get harder for
most americans i don't think it's a bad
thing
i think uh american gluttony is
resulting in this like lost generation
uh the millennial generation are the
softest of soft we've seen in a long
time and that's probably why we're you
know the fourth turning stress our
generational theory it's probably why
things are getting bad in the first
place these are people who don't work
don't want to work complain about the
little work they have to do and demand
the government pay them free you know
just give them money for no reason the
money comes out of the pockets of those
who actually do work sorry but if you
live in new york and you work for
buzzfeed you're not actually producing
anything of value to society and and for
that matter i'll be completely real and
say i know a lot of people like this
show but damn sometimes i'm surprised
that we sit around a table talking about
our thoughts and feelings and we make
more money than a plumber does plumber
actually make sure your poop goes away
that's in many ways the collective work
of trades groups electricians machinists
as people noted before substantially
more value than even than even what we
do to be fair to us i understand that
defending that you know liberty freedom
and supporting the working class who are
actually making everything possible is
still a good thing it's important to
have you know a culture that that
surround you know maintains these values
and and ideas but man we sure got a
whole lot of millennials who do
literally nothing and complain about
everything it's also gen x a lot of
people it's the gut biome i think has
destroyed motivation people smile yeah
they're saying gluttony too much of that
gunk in your gut and you just you get up
and it's like i'm tired i'm i
i don't know i'm bored you understand
that boredom is not boredom is not
supposed to happen
everything is so stimulating clear your
gut and you'll see it
well i mean i would
i i think it's more of a will power
thing people are so well fed that they
don't really have to hunger and
they don't really chase things or seek
out goals the way people of the past and
i sort of hear what you're saying i
wouldn't put it exactly that way i
wouldn't say that boredom isn't supposed
to happen i would say that it's
something we're supposed to allow to
happen so that we can find interesting
things to focus on rather than just
looking at our smartphone or seeing
what's on television or browsing the
internet boredom boredom shouldn't exist
yeah when you're calm and you're it's
the most relaxing thing
thoughts are an annoyance at that point
well i mean i think that we should allow
for moments of boredom to come
because that's when creativity really
starts to flourish you start coming up
with ideas on your own or figuring out
things to do we should if every time
that board starts to kick in you look at
your phone and start scrolling you're
never going to be i don't think you're
talking about boredom i think we're
talking about listlessness or laziness
how do you define relaxation yeah i
would define boredom as
when
i think almost by definition it's when
you you aren't sure what to focus on or
nothing is grabbing your attention i
would say boredom is when nothing is
grabbing your attention i think that's a
fair way of defining it i'm never bored
i have never i think i think sometimes i
think sometimes it's it's good to allow
yourself to be in a situation where
you're not sure what to focus on because
that means you're not looking at all the
traditional things that are grasping for
your attention at all times and you're
looking you're trying to find something
deeper like not you could be in a
position where you're not focusing on
anything but not be bored i is a point i
would like to make
it's like yes
boredom in my opinion is a result of
it's it's lux it's luxury based
stagnation
it's that
we we live in such luxury that people
can sit there and be like i have
literally nothing to do
well if you have a mission if you have
drive and you have purpose you literally
will never experience that but for so
many people they have no purpose boredom
arises what do i do now i got off work i
have money for my bills my rent is paid
what do i do
yeah put something in my stomach and
then not have to create something
because i i'm busy digesting yeah
they're they're i have down time down
time is like man i'm exhausted you know
so oh i'll here here's what i did today
i woke up immediately got to work
finished work around two immediately
skated for two hours ate food and sat
and then sat for about an hour or so to
try and just like
rest not boredom exhaustion then i get
cleaned up to come on the show and here
we are on the show once again we're
going to finish a show and then i'm
going to go to bed then i'm going to
wake up and do it all over again there's
no on the weekends it's relaxation not
boredom it's like woof i need to chill
wow man i am wiped out yeah i guess
maybe we're defining the term
differently or maybe we disagree but i
think a little bit of boredom every now
and again is healthy i bet we're
slightly defining it differently yeah
that could be possible boredom to me is
usually when someone like you said i
don't know what to do and you're sitting
there confused you're not sure what to
focus on yeah or or the things that you
should be doing are not immediately
obvious to you when i think so often
when people get that first
dose of boredom
their instinct is to run to some form of
entertainment i want to look at my phone
i want to look at my computer i want to
see what's on television instead of
sitting there and going why don't i
imagine a story why don't i start
picking at a guitar why don't i learn an
instrument or a hobby or something along
those lines you see that's
for for someone like me
i've i've had you know i've been bored
before for to you know to a certain
degree but for for the most part i
probably experienced substantially left
boredom and i think that's something you
get when you're a kid i think it's
something you you know if you grow up
with no purpose and no meaning you're
probably going to find yourself bored
very very often unsure of what to do
with yourself for me it was too much to
do all the time i played music i
skateboarded i was constantly reading
the news i was constantly learning i
used to do flash animations i used to
make websites i was always just trying
to do something understand something or
solve something what kind of what was
your diet like do you guys eat a lot of
sugar growing up
oh i had a lot of candy but was it was
it allowed to have soda in the house
did we yeah
yeah we had fresca oh
and then we had royal crown cola
that was rc way better than pepsico
it was kind of banned from our house my
mom wouldn't let us have soda in the
house so at the time i hated it because
i was wanting sugar sure sure and i go
to the drug mart and get sugar and like
uh lemon heads and you know spree and
all this but i had not having in my diet
helped me in later life i used to make
video games on uh back in the day i was
i would do some flash programming i
would do some uh there was a thing
called click and play used to exist in
games factory and then multimedia fusion
i use those but then so when i wasn't
doing that i was playing magic the
gathering i was playing pokemon i was
skateboarding so i was literally always
doing something just like there was
never a period of where i wasn't doing
anything we weren't well off by any
means my skateboard was always like
you'd get worn down and then i'd be
riding a crusty board for a while and
then i didn't have the best cards ever
so it became really hard to be
competitive in any of these things like
magic or whatever but i was always doing
something it was there was always
somewhere to be and then if i wasn't
doing any of those things there was like
just people to hang out with talk about
and so we were always off on adventures
i gotta say i think skateboarding is one
of the most powerful things you can do
for a kid because when i first started
skating first of all it gives you drive
and direction you've got something to
accomplish it's tangible it's in front
of you you know how to do it you've seen
people do it now you need to accomplish
it you get it what's the next step
then what happens is there's fears to
overcome dropping in on a half pipe is
scary but you have to do it and you're
gonna fall the first time not everybody
but 95 chance you're gonna fall and get
hurt and you have to if you want to
overcome that hurdle then the other
thing that skateboarding does is we
started exploring me and all my friends
would would travel around going to
different neighborhoods trying to find
new places to skate meeting new people
expanding our reach throughout the city
then eventually i went to other cities
and suburbs and other states and then
traveled around the country outside
adventure that's a big part of it being
in nature i think uh andrew huberman was
he's a neuroscientist was saying every
human should at least for 15 minutes a
day gaze into the horizon it does
something to the brain he explains it
way better than i do but i suggest
checking out andrew huberman he's a
genius he has a great podcast on youtube
outdoor activity and also hanging from
branches apparently is very good for
your balance according to ben stewart i
know that it's such a boomer thing to
say but the only reason it's a boomer
thing to say is because every generation
before them said it and it's like one of
the wise things they actually retained
but kids just don't spend enough time
outside anymore and sad because what
you're talking about going out and
exploring with your friends i did
similar things and we were fortunate
because our parents didn't really want
us to have game systems we didn't get
them until we were a bit older we didn't
have cable in our house so we pretty
much had to go outside and find things
to do i knew so many kids in my
generation and especially in the
generation a little bit after me
where
the kids kind of didn't really develop a
personality because all they were doing
was focusing on electronics and i'm not
saying that you can't develop skills or
some personality with electronics either
you know you like you said you can learn
to code you can learn to build computers
that's all really productive but it's
just sad that this sense of exploration
has been lost because so many kids will
just find it in their video game system
or nowadays in their smartphone well
something something that was i think
really good for me growing up as i was
an athlete i think sports are a really
important thing that you can that you
can do for a kid you know it's it
teaches teamwork you know you're working
towards a goal of winning with a bunch
of people you meet friends that way like
so for me that was something that i
think really helped me it also teaches
you a lot of like you know values of
hard work you know working hard to get
to the highest level in your sport
um and i think you know i think the
world would be a better place if we had
if we had a lot of athletes well yeah i
think that's interesting
one more thing i want to point out here
which is is different between the time
and i know we're not all the same age
but the times respectively that we were
all raised in and how kids are being
raised now is even though we did have
all sorts of you know distracting
electronic gadgets at least when you
were outside you were outside now with
these smartphones they're constantly
online even when they're outdoors it's a
very unhealthy thing like they don't get
to take a break from that technological
infrastructure the way we could when we
were kids you could just kind of go out
into the woods or go into the forest or
go to your local pond with your siblings
and really be in nature and that's not
possible anymore because they always
have everything at their fingertips i
wonder if the wi-fi is agitating people
too that might have some
the countries
in this upcoming civil war the barriers
the borders
they're digital
that's why you know bill maher was like
you know we can't have a civil war
because the mason-dixon line would go
through nana's kitchen so
well sure
people are now polarizing based on the
ideology they hold based on digital
boundaries so there are bubbles on
twitter there's a left bubble and a
right bubble and you can actually map it
out there's been these really great
visualizations showing how they like
they like clash and then spread out and
you have like the right which is mostly
the far right's all like destroyed and
banned so you have like this big clump
of like center right and then you have
this huge splash of far left those are
the borders of the upcoming or the
current cold civil wars of what we're
going to call it well i
i find that fascinating because there is
an old george george bernard shaw quote
he said the class warfare of the future
will be fought between competing
intellectual classes for the souls of
our children thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you